I'm tired of Australia
hold on hold on I don't want to talk
about it anymore why I want to talk
about it anime
are we doing it are we actually talking
about anime on trash face I just wanna
listen it feels like such a waste to
have a studio audience and not say some
anime opinions you know what I mean
right for example let me just let me
just say something and you guys react to
how it makes you feel okay
spy family
is mid
[Applause]
Gotti I just wanted to try it I'm sorry
okay all right actually it's funny that
you brought it up because I feel like
for the first time in about 10 years uh
the boys come up to me like last week uh
and Joe and Joey especially get uh Joey
especially says gone you're not gonna
believe this okay I go what he said I
watched 15 episodes of anime last week I
was like no way the anime man there's no
way
that's right I'm back baby he's back
yeah
um I just had like a day off one weekend
this is like a few days before we flew
to Melbourne
um and I was just like yeah I don't know
what's come over me but
I wanna I wanna watch anime disgusting
and I think it's because especially this
season is just so incredibly stacked or
I'm just like okay there's I feel
there's too many good shows not to watch
so I watched uh first at the time there
was only two episodes of oceanico
[Applause]
say about that it's
it's the manga was so freaking good so I
knew it was going to be good uh I
watched uh what's called English hell's
Paradise hell's Paradise Paradise which
is also like mapper never misses so they
killed her with that and I actually
finally finished an anime that I had had
on hold for the longest time oh oh okay
and because it was so long I I decided
to just go back to episode one and just
like binge all 12 episodes I finally
finished botchy The Rock you've
yeah you finished watching the rock yeah
because I think I'd watch it up until
like episode five or six and then I just
like forgot about and I was like I I
should actually just kind of finish this
so I've just binged in one day and uh
yeah it's good
but
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait Joey Joey what what do you
mean
but
it is so incredibly cringe
okay okay I'm sorry you like that I mean
I I found that yes it is incredibly
incredibly cringe but it was kind of
like
a self-reflective cringe because it was
so relatable that I found myself
cringing at some some points in it and
it was kind of like the closest thing I
found to something like peep show or
Inbetweeners but like anime form where I
would watch scenes and I'd be like this
is so [__] painful yeah yeah okay so
like when I went into Bocce The Rock
right initially before I decided to
watch it all again right my my
understanding of it after reading the
synopsis I was like oh this is chaon but
if the main character was the girl from
watamote
which bought you fans
that's what the show is
there's no denying that that's exactly
what that show is right it is a
incredibly socially awkward girl
making a band and making music this is
all the things I hate
this is just everything I don't
understand so I went into it right and
look granted the art and animation is
phenomenal like I can I can see why
people adore this show right but you
pointed out saying oh I cringe at the
fact that it was relatable yeah
no one is that socially awkward I'm
sorry not even anime fans and that's
stooping low no one not not even anime
fans of that socially all is anyone that
socially awkward no no you think you are
that's [__] no no no you put your
hand up you put your hand up you're
already more sociable okay
do you guys like Moshi the rock or what
are you feeling
okay good I like you guys yeah okay
like I granted like I understand why the
show is incredibly popular right because
you know there was a lot of aspects of
the show I really enjoy like the music
is [__] Stellar like especially that
last episode when they do those like
full performances of those songs I was
like hell yeah this is great [__]
music it's like chaon but they're
actually grinding man they're actually
working towards something and I respect
that okay yeah and I totally respected
that as well but like I don't know up
until like around like episode five and
six I just got so so frustrated at the
main character I was just like look I
know how this is gonna go all right
you're gonna go into your own world
thinking about all the horrible what ifs
of this like one social situation which
at the end of the day doesn't even
[__] matter right and then you're
gonna come out of it and you're going to
be like oh you know what it was fine all
along that's how every episode ends in
vulture the Rock and I'm like all right
can we just like hurry up please can you
just like get to the music making
process I much prefer that
I don't know is that a hot take no do
you like do you think do you think it's
overrated
yes
I haven't I haven't seen it
I'm just saying yes after I finally
finished it I think I could definitively
say
it's slightly overrated
okay okay the more important question
yeah which ones prefer Bocce the rock or
chaos K on 100 percent
I'm sorry no no man okay here's the
thing okay here's the thing okay explain
yourself can we explain yourself take a
moment to appreciate that we're [__]
talking about Adam yeah in front of like
too many people why do we care about
this okay here's the thing right I don't
appreciate people comparing Bocce The
Rock to K on yeah and the big reason is
because I will not stand for it I am
going to go Karen mode for a second and
I will not stand for the comparison
between K on and Lodge of The Rock
because bought you the rock right as you
said there is like okay yes
let me finish I'm trolling I do a little
trolling gear into that the the thing
that I enjoyed if I bought you the rock
as you said right is that there's like a
progression happening yeah it's like
it's like a coming-of-age story right
like a like a like a much like a growth
in like character and maturity right by
using you know botchy learning to become
social through their bandmates and like
being in this like very group oriented
activity right yeah and you know that
that aspect of the story I really liked
because it's like that part of that show
was quite relatable because you know
we've all been in situations where it's
like oh I want to do something cool but
I don't have the courage to do it myself
and so you get like-minded people around
you to like push you forward right like
that's a great sentiment to have in a
story
they didn't even give a hint of that
because from episode one there was no
[__] story right the whole point of
chaon it's like watching chaon is like
watching like a bunch of exotic birds in
a cage you know it's like they'd look
really cute and pretty but you know
they're not going to do anything they're
not gonna be like oh the the birds
suddenly uh started talking and uh you
know making a revelation like what is
this you don't you don't expect when
you're looking at a cage full of exotic
birds you don't expect anything
grandiose from it but you still stand
there and watch it and enjoy yourself
that's what chaos
what is this bird analogy is because I
like birds okay
it's like going to a zoo basically and
just like
Kion is like the experience of going to
a zoo and seeing your favorite animal
right you're just watching them do their
thing you don't expect anything good to
come out of it but maybe every now and
then they might [__] themselves
let me cook let me cook right and so the
reason why I don't appreciate the the
comparison between Canon and Bocce is
because they went into the whole cute
girls making music thing at a completely
different angle right there wasn't
enough zoos actually I just realized
that there wasn't enough animals no
there wasn't I had to bring the
australianism into it right so that's
why like you know I if there was a show
to compare Bocce to right in the world
of anime more than chaon I would say
Beck [__] off joey yes
who's seen back here okay
because both shows are about you know uh
a dude a main character or a girl in the
case with a boji right wanting to start
a band but he doesn't have the courage
to do it himself so he gets like-minded
individuals to make that dream a reality
granta the main character of Beck isn't
as socially a nabbed as right but the
the it's the same type of story right
but yeah but I would argue that Bocce is
like right in the middle of of K on and
back that's that's that it was like The
Best of Both Worlds is that in terms of
enjoyability though sorry is that in
terms of enjoyability
yes because everybody knows Beck is okay
yeah I feel like my I'm like the kitten
the divorced parents accurate like what
what do they start
hey you're the one who wanted to talk
now you can't blame it I know I didn't
expect you to go this way
I I think I can sum this up in one line
sure all right is it because she's not
like you for real
no
in fact
it related to the most was the drunk
bass player girl who everybody knows is
the best character in bocce everyone
knows she's the best she's the best all
right all right I agree I agree yeah
finally something we can agree on yes
when you're talking then it just
reminded me of the you know the um the
Emoji that's just the nerd
I don't know why I wasn't trying to be
mean
[Laughter]
but other than that yeah
um yeah have we all seen have we all
seen oshinuku
yeah you've you've even seen that right
corner I have what did you think about
it it was good
but it was weird
explain weird how well okay so first of
all I can't spoil live because I can't
just have you delete your ears in the
episode we can just be like spoiler
warning please leave so I won't spoil
okay unless you want me to I'm getting
that way but I could and you couldn't do
anything about it
and you can't leave
I won't though I won't
I won't I won't
I'll stop it's it it feels it's really
weird because it just seems like I was
watching it I was like huh this is just
like vtubers
with all the secrets and okay it's like
it's like everything seemed like online
stuff too it was really weird yeah yeah
I think that's intense I think that's
what's so good about oceanico it's kind
of like I think I think I described it
as like Black Mirror but for the
Japanese everything's Black Mirror okay
okay okay it is so it is it's like it's
just a more depressing look and I
honestly a more honest look at you know
how the idol industry is everyone knows
sucks
yeah but the good thing about oceanico
is that like uh later down the line they
go into so much more than that I hope
yeah and it's like of every corner of
the entertainment industry which is like
the more you read the Manga you're just
like oh man this this is too real I have
to like close this especially as a
YouTuber I'm just like oh my God I did
not it's like when you accidentally like
stumble upon a hate comment and it just
ruins your day you know it's just like I
didn't I didn't need to see that right
now I I knew it was there I just didn't
want to see it it has one of the most
like insane premises to explain to
someone
you sound insane if you say you like
this show and then you're like oh my the
way uh it's about a dude who was in love
with a girl and then Becomes Her Child
so
bro you just spoiled it that's not a
spoiler that's the first [__] 10
minutes
yeah so did you go into a blind I'm
curious no because remember we did the
string where we kind of talked about it
uh the manga did we talk yes we did we
got paid too
we got paid to talk about the anime
rankings oh sorry the manga right oh oh
yes and then when you told me about the
show I was like what the [__]
what the [__] dude there's so much weird
anime there's so much stuff that's so
it's like you you know we've gotten to
the point that we've gone too far when
that's one of the more tame things this
season like God was telling me about
this anime about a dude who gets
reincarnated as a girl's dog
yeah we uh we don't talk about that have
you guys seen this
don't what are you excited about it why
were you clapping what
I saw one person clapping yeah I
couldn't it's anime like that where I'm
like oh that's why I stopped watching
yeah this is this is where anime has
gone too yeah okay it doesn't sound that
bad when you say that but then when you
find out what happens in the show you're
like oh God oh God we should have we
should have stopped it's the whole POV
man if they didn't make a POV it just
would have been it's POV it's POV yeah
it's POV if it wasn't POV it I mean it
still would have been weird but it
wouldn't have been as weird you know POV
just makes everything creepier
because the only things that are shot at
POV are Pawn
sure that is true that's the only place
we actually see POV and we like it right
oh my God yeah and then uh and then the
other show I watched was uh hell's
Paradise Health Paradise oh my God like
again this is another one like oceanico
I had read uh like did you read the
Manga for that yeah okay I'm only
watching the anime and like what I'm
getting from hell's Paradise is
everything that I I'm never gonna get
from Hunters uh Hunter Hunters Dark
Continent Arc
yeah yeah yeah because anyone caught up
on Hunter Hunter to the point where it
is because it's never going to continue
yeah trick question it's never
continuing okay like full review wow
yeah no what I think what I liked about
uh hell's Paradise is that even though
it's a Shonen Jump manga it just feels
like it's gone back to like the early
2000s like just like we don't give a
[__] anymore just like let's just make
it the most gory messed up show but also
make it like just I don't know really
cool and entertaining and it's like like
the monster designs in Hell's Paradise
are like legitimate nightmare fuel like
it's terrifying it's like it's like some
like Bleach hollow [__] you know like
yeah been meaning to watch it but I
wanted to wait for more episodes to come
out yeah it feels like the kind of show
that I want to watch like all of it and
one yeah I really regret starting it now
because I have to wait late every week
now dude this is like I've been watching
Finland Saga if you haven't watched it
you should watch it oh hell yeah hell
yeah hell yeah and it's amazing but
watching people play Farmville week by
week is so slow yeah that's why I'm
waiting for it to just finish I'm an
idiot I should have waited longer yeah
yeah because I think the manga's on the
final Arc right now yeah yeah it's funny
because when villain Saga season 2
started airing I thought a lot of people
were gonna drop it because it was a very
very different from season one yeah very
slow about a totally different thing now
the violence is gone uh but generally
people don't seem to be complaining I
don't know I think I think it's because
like they've just heard through the
great find where it's like just just
live just get past this part and it'll
be worth it I think Australia would like
it because it's about the English
getting [__] as well so I think like
it's good that's for sure that's true